hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions start with two
circles that are tangent to each other
draw the diameter of the large circle
and note that this distance between the
two circles is 10 now draw another
diameter of the large circle that's
perpendicular and at these points the
distance between the two circles is 18
the question is what is the area in
between the two circles this is adapted
from a problem for 14 to 16 year-olds
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so what's the answer to this problem
before I get to that I actually want to
solve a different problem let's swap the
numbers 10 and 18 because this is the
actual problem that was asked of 14 to
16 year-olds how can we solve this we'll
get started
by writing the letter R for the radius
of the small circle this distance will
also be R and now 2r plus 18 will equal
the diameter of the large circle this
means half of that or R plus 9 will be
the large radius so this distance will
be R plus 9 that means the two circles
have a distance of 9 between their
centers now since the large radius is R
plus 9 this distance will also be R plus
9 since the distance between the two
circles is 10 that means this distance
here has to be R minus 1 because R minus
1 plus 10 is equal to R plus 9 now let's
draw a radius of the small circle and we
actually have a right triangle right
here
that means 9 squared plus the quantity R
minus 1 squared is equal to R squared we
have a single equation in the variable R
and we can solve it we get that R is
equal to 41 now recall that the large
circles radius is equal to R plus 9 we
can solve for the shaded area as the
area of the large circle minus the area
of the small circle it'll be this
formula and it simplifies and that will
be equal to 819 pi and that's the answer
so now what about the original problem
where the distances of 10 and 18 were
swapped well you could go about it
exactly in the same method as we just
did let's let R be the radius of the
small circle and then we'll calculate
the distance between the Centers of the
two circles in this case it works out to
be 5 we then calculate this vertical
distance
and it ends up being our -13 so we get a
right triangle and we again use the
Pythagorean theorem we then solve for R
and get that r is equal to 97 over 13
now before you go any further you need
to think for a minute if R is equal to
97 over 13 what is the value of R minus
13 if you work it out it's actually
going to be a negative number and this
should raise a red flag it is absurd to
have a negative length in this geometry
problem so something has gone wrong
since all of our steps were valid we can
only conclude one thing the correct
answer is that the dimensions in this
problem are actually impossible I think
it's great to have such trick problems
once in a while so that students don't
just apply formulas blindly and they
actually think about what they're
calculating thanks for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]